the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today actually has us
backtrack a little bit to a concept
which is actually more fundamental than
that of differentiability it's the topic
which is called continuous functions in
other words our lecture today is
concerned with a topic called
continuity and actually the topic of
continuity had its roots way back at the
beginning of our course when we first
raised the question does the limit of f
of X as X approach a equal f of a
remember when we first started talking
about the limit concept our intuitive
approach was to say look at as X gets
arbitrarily close to a f of X gets
arbitrarily close to f of a and we saw
that this particular definition had a
few loopholes in it even though
intuitively this is what we would have
liked and so what I want to do today is
to see what happens if we can be sure
that the limit of f of X as X approaches
a equals F of a what is implied if this
happens to be a true statement and my
first claim is is that it is implicitly
implied that F of a must at least make
sense otherwise we wouldn't have written
it over here in other words F must be
defined when x equals a F of a must be
defined now to correlate that with
material that we've had previously let's
go back to an example that we've
discussed before or at least an example
which is close to something we've
studied before let's define f of X to be
x squared minus 1 over X minus 1 now you
see as long as X is not equal to 1 we
can cancel X minus 1 from both numerator
and denominator leaving this equal to X
plus 1 and we then see what that the
limit of f of X as X approaches 1 is
equal to 2 on the other hand notice that
F of 1 turns out to be 0 over 0 in this
case which is undefined in other words
in this particular case the limit of f
of X as X approaches 1 is not equal to F
of 1 if only because F of 1 isn't even
defined and again by way of a review
let's look at this thing pictorially
remember x squared minus 1 over X minus
1 is X plus 1
except when x equals 1 consequently to
graph y equals x squared minus 1 over X
minus 1 we simply graph y equals x plus
1 with the point corresponding to x
equals 1 meaning the point 1 comma 2
deleted in other words this with this
point deleted is the graph y equals x
squared minus 1 over X minus 1 you see
again there is no definition at x equals
1 because this point is missing it would
be the 0 over 0 form now to be sure we
can clean this up in the sense that we
could define a new function G of X to be
x squared minus 1 over X minus 1 as long
as X is not equal to 1 and define it to
be 2 when x equals 1 which by the way
geometrically is just a fancy way of
writing the equation of the line y
equals x plus 1 in other words all we're
saying is is that letting G of X be 2
when x equals 1 plug is the little hole
that appears over here now again I hope
that this seems fairly familiar from our
discussion on limits but for the time
being all I want us to see is that as
soon as you write down that the limit of
f of X as X approaches a equals F of a
you at least imply that F of a must be
defined
let's see another property that's
implied by our definition I claim as you
might expect that I that if the limit of
f of X as X approaches a is f of a that
means that f of X is near f of a when X
is near a in other words my claim is
that the curve y equals f of X is
unbroken in a neighborhood of x equals a
and to see what I mean by that let's
look at this picture over here suppose
for example that our curve y equals f of
X let me darken this up so that we can
see it a little better
suppose that curve had a break as x
equals
a okay now let's say f of a is over here
what I could do is now pick an interval
surrounding f of a if there was a break
over here such that this ban never
touched or included the top curve here
now notice from this point of view that
no matter how close X gets to a as long
as X is greater than a f of X which is
up here on this dark curve can never be
with an epsilon of f of a in other words
if there's a break in the curve if
there's a break in the curve I could
always fix it up so at the limit of f of
X as X approaches a is not equal to f of
a at any rate with these two properties
as motivation let us now give our basic
definition and the basic definition is
simply this a function f is called
continuous at x equals a precisely if
this if the property that we were
discussing is present namely if the
limit of f of X as X approaches a is
equal to f of a we generalize this
definition and say F is called
continuous on the entire interval I R on
the interval I if the limit of f of X as
X approaches a is equal to f of a for
each a in I in other words notice that
our first definition is a local property
namely we defined continuous or
continuity at a given value and then if
the function happens to be continuous at
every point then we call the function
itself continuous what the thing means
pictorially is that if the function is
continuous at x equals a it means that
in terms of the graph of the function
that in a neighborhood of the point a
comma f of a on the graph in a
neighborhood of that point in other
words in a sufficiently small interval
surrounding that point the curve itself
must be unbroken now you see this may
sound trivial remember when we first
started talking about limits we had the
feeling
limit of f of X as X approaches a should
always equal F of a and the reason for
this was that instinctively
we seem to always think of continuous
functions we think of what things
changing in such a way that the graph of
the change is unbroken even though of
course there are places with
discontinuities occur at any rate what
I'm saying is is that many of the
results that I now want to discuss with
you which are very important properties
of continuous functions may seem
self-evident because we keep thinking
about any function as being continuous
but I will try to emphasize the fact
that these properties are not true if
the function is not continuous I also
would like to show a balance between
geometric ideas and analytic ideas in
other words let me start off by seeing
what things seem to follow about
continuous functions based primarily on
the graph idea for example I claim that
continuous functions assume their
maximum and minimum values on any closed
interval now this sounds like a big
mouthful and it also sounds kind of
trivia doesn't any function have a
maximum and minimum value on a closed
interval and the answer is no for
example take the curve y equals 1 over X
minus 1 squared notice that when X is 1
Y is infinite which means that if we
graph this particular function we find
that the graph does something like this
in other words it goes it jumps up here
comes back etc now what is the highest
value or what is the highest point on
our graph here well notice that the
graph is broken here if this it's
discontinuous when x equals 1 notice
that the curve rises to infinity in
other words the maximum value is
undefined on this particular closed
interval you see there's a jump over
here of course the fact that this is an
infinite jump may make you feel uneasy
if you don't feel comfortable with
infinity so let me paraphrase this just
a little bit in terms of a finite jump
let me write down the following function
let's think of the curve let's think of
the function f of X
equals x if X is less than 1 then as
soon as X is at least as big as 1 the
function becomes minus X in other words
graphically we have the line y equals x
from 0 up to 1 but not including 1 and
then at 1 the function jumps down to
minus 1 and becomes the line y equals
minus x let's look for example at the
closed interval again from 0 to 2 what
is the biggest value what is the maximum
that the function can have if x is
between 0 & 2 well notice that as X gets
closer and closer to 1 f of X gets
closer and closer to 1 but f of X never
equals exactly 1 because when X is 1 the
curve jumps down to here in other words
notice that as X gets arbitrarily close
to 1 f of X increases and gets
arbitrarily close to but never equals 1
in other words notice that by picking X
to be less than 1 we can make f of X as
close to 1 as we want but we can never
make it exactly equal to 1 because of
this jump which takes place over here
you see this discontinuity caused us a
little bit of difficulty by the way we
can use this example from another point
of view if we just look at the part
where it says f of X is equal to X where
X is less than 1 that means we'll just
look at this pi of the curve notice that
this part of the curve is unbroken
and yet as X approaches 1 f of X
approaches but never equals 1 which
means that to get the maximum value in
here I would have to include the end
point x equals 1 in other words notice
that even if the function is continuous
if the interval is open it may not
assume the maximum value in other words
you may not be able to find the value of
x in that interval such that the
function will be maximum at that
particular value now again this is
making a mountain out of a molehill in
terms of your intuition because these
are results which I'm sure you believe
are true anyway in other words it seems
to be true but all I hope is that these
little examples here show you what
the importance of continuity is because
as we progress later in our work these
so-called fine points are going to
become crucial in many of our proofs and
by the way I think it's a truism to say
that if you make fine points seem very
very important before you get to use
them and don't emphasize them people
tend to think that you overestimated
your case so I prefer not to beat this
to death and wait until such times in
our course that we need these results
before I emphasize them more so these
are results which are in the textbook
which I'll test you on and the exercise
isn't alike but just want to go through
with you now so that you get an overall
idea
another result that's rather clear
geometrically is something called the
intermediate value theorem suppose that
f is continuous on the closed interval
from A to B and without loss of
generality let's suppose f of a is less
than f of B the same kind of an argument
will hold if F of B were less than F of
a but I just need some sort of an
orientation now I say let m be any
number such that M is what between F of
a and F of B in other words M is greater
than F of a but less than F of B you see
if F of B were less than F of a I would
just reverse the inequality signs here
at any rate what my claim is that we can
find the number C in the open interval
from A to B such that F of C equals M
again this may sound kind of complicated
all it says in terms of a picture is
this if our curve goes from point one to
point two okay where the height of p1 is
f of a and the height of p2 is f of B
then it must assume every intermediary
height between F of a and F of B on that
particular interval again you can think
of that in terms of a of an automobile
if you want if an automobile goes from a
speed of 20 miles an hour to a speed of
30 miles per hour in what we think of as
being continuous motion then at some
time in that interval it must have had
any particular any particular speed you
want to mention
between 20 and 30 miles in other words
we don't visualize a car going from 20
miles an hour to 30 miles an hour say
we're now at one time having passed the
speed of 27 miles per hour or some such
thing and geometrically you see this
proof is very simple namely draw the
line y equals M and now what you're
saying is you want to get from this
point to this point and the idea is that
the only way you can get from this point
to this point without crossing this line
is if someplace along the way you jump
over this line in other words
geometrically all you're saying is look
at if I have to join p1 to p2 with an
unbroken line then I must cross the line
y equals M someplace by the way notice I
say is at least one place the curve
could have done something like this for
example but the important point is what
there's at least one number C such that
F of C equals M again somebody might
think in terms of an end-run and saying
quick we have done something like this
and not cross this line that brings us
back again to our concept of single
valued miss in other words notice if we
remove the restriction that F would be a
single valued function in other words if
F can double back notice that if we
think of the line y equals M as being
endless the point remains what that you
must someplace cross this line in going
from p1 to p2 but if we remove the
single valued restriction then the point
at which you cross this line would not
have to be C in this case C would not be
in the open interval from A to B since F
is not single value and what I'm hoping
this discussion does for us is gives us
a good geometric feeling as to what is
happening in terms of a continuous
function by the same token remember our
basic definition of continuity
goes back to our concept of limit and
our concept of limit has been cemented
down fairly firmly from an analytical
point of view and that means that we can
also see these things theoretically as
well as pictorially and hopefully what
we will do is combine pictorial and
analytic aspects to the best possible
advantage for solving problems but to
show you what I mean by this let's look
at a few analytical properties of
continuous functions for example suppose
F and G are both continuous at x equals
a and suppose we define H to be the sum
of F and G in other words H of X is f of
X plus G of X ok let's compute the limit
of H of X as X approaches a by
definition the limit of H of X as X
approaches a is the limit of the
quantity f of X plus G of X as X
approaches a now if we look at this
particular expression notice that
because of our theorems on limits we can
do an awful lot with this without having
to make any recourse to a picture at all
for example notice that we can say right
away that since the limit of a Sommers
are some of the limits this is the limit
of f of X as X approaches a plus the
limit of G of X as X approaches a
secondly since F and G are continuous at
x equals a by definition of continuous
at x equals a this says that the limit
of f of X as X approaches a is f of a
the limit of G of X as X approaches a is
G of a therefore this expression is f of
a plus G of a but by the definition of H
this is just H of a and if we now look
at this we see what that the limit of H
of X as X approaches a equals H of a
notice that this result came about under
the assumption that F and G were both
continuous at x equals a and what have
we proven over here this is precisely
the statement that H is continuous at x
equals a in other words what we've now
proven analytically is as a sum of two
continuous functions is a continuous
function by induction we could prove
this for more than for the sum of more
than two we can in a similar way by
using limit
prove things like the product of two
continuous functions is continuous etc
we also were on the verge of a topic
like this when we talked about
differentiability sometime back namely I
claim that there is an interesting
connection between differentiable and
continuous and that the connection is
that any differentiable function is
continuous and by the way the proofs
utilizes that which we used in our first
lecture on derivatives in this block
namely we take the expression F event to
show that if F prime of a exists that F
must be continuous at x equals a that
means we want to show that the limit of
f of X as X approaches a is f of a and
that's the same as saying we want to
show that this difference approaches
zero in the limit and the trick is we
take f of X minus F of a and write it as
f of X minus F of a divided by X minus a
times X minus a the idea being that
we'll now take the limit as X approaches
a the limit of a product is the product
of the limits the limit of this as X
approaches a is just going to be f prime
of a that's our definition of derivative
and the limit of X minus a as X
approaches a is just 0 in other words
put in these steps together look what we
get the limit as X approaches a f of X
minus f of a is the limit as X
approaches a of this bracketed
expression f of X minus F of a over X
minus a times the limit of X minus a as
X approaches a by definition F being
differentiable at a means that this
limit exists and is in fact F prime of a
but any finite number times 0 is still 0
and therefore it follows that the limit
of f of X as X approaches a is f of a
there's a legitimate analytic proof that
differentiability implies continuity now
it's not necessarily true that
continuity implies differentiability and
you see even though you can prove these
things analytically if you don't form
some picture in your mind you frequently
will my wind up memorizing results
rather than having a
for them what I mean by having pictures
and proofs coexist is this instead of
saying to yourself let's see continuity
is a weaker condition than
differentiability it's a strong which
one is it you say look at we identify
continuity with unbroken remember
continuous means unbroken what the
differentiable main differentiable meant
that the curve had a tangent line and
that in turn meant that the curve was
smooth in other words we may think of
differentiable as the geometric analogue
of smoothness continuity as the
geometric analogue of unbroken s and now
I think it's very easy to see
pictorially that a smooth curve must be
unbroken but an unbroken curve doesn't
have to be smooth and in fact a very
trivial illustration of this is the
graph y equals the absolute value of x
you see where what happens here at the
origin notice that we have a sharp
corner but that the curve itself is
unbroken there you see I can draw the
curve without taking the pencil off the
paper the chalk off the board
that's what continuity means from an
intuitive point of view yet I have a
sharp corner it's not smooth here that's
why I write smooth and quotation marks
hopefully the textbook together with our
exercises will make this much clearer to
you but notice again in terms of a
picture how an unbroken curve doesn't
have to be smooth but a smooth curve has
to be unbroken now the point is we could
say much more about continuous functions
I think that all we have to say though
has already been said it'll be
reinforced in the text
we'll have exercises on this but the
important thing for now is to understand
what we mean by continuous how we will
use it in the future and at any rate
we'll be talking about that more later
and so until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate